كرتون بريطانيه سبق موافقه لندن على ارسال
دبابات تشالنجر 2 اوكرانيا والشرط هو منع
السلاح القوات الروسيه على هذه الدبابات
عبر تقييد استخدامها من قبل الجيش
الاوكراني حيث يسعى كبار الضباط في القوات
المسلحه البريطانيه مع مدراهم الاوكرانيين
لتجنب نشر دباباتهم من طراز تشالنجر 2 في
المناطق المصنفه بالخطره وفقا صحف
بريطانيه واقترح الضباط مجموعه خيارات في
حال اصابه او تعطل تشالنجر ساحات المعركه
ففي حال تم تدمير خزان او تعطيله الخيار
الاول يتمثل دائما بمحاوله الاسترداد
الذاتي القيام دبابه اخرى بسحبها او
استخدام مدرعه اصلاح ومركبه اصلاح مدرعه
متخصصه واضمن الخيارات ايضا وجود مرتزقه
على حبه الاستعداد لاستعاده الدبابات
المتضرره هذا واكدت هنا مصادر بريطانيه ان
الروس بحاجه للاستلاء على تشالنجر ولو
جزئيا للدعايه اولا ولتحصيل اسرارها ثانيا
لاسيما ان بريطانيا لطالما تباهت بسجلها
شبه المثالي مع دبابات تشالنجر شهدت تدمير
ثلاث دبابات من هذا الطراز فقط علما بان
بريطانيا تمتلك حوالي
227 دبابه تشالنجر في مخزونها 60 منها فقط
في حاله يمكن نشرها وفقارير
[موسيقى]